nein sie sich 15 sie liegt ist schon
wieder 15 sie liegt eindeutig das war
der 2
[Musik]
es wird knapp kurz gekommen war mein
video jahr wollte ich hoffe euch jetzt
gut ich habe mir für heute mal wieder
was ganz spezielles einig das ganze
kommt irgendwie aus amerika ich hab das
doch meiner stelle gesehen und zwar
heißt das irgendwie great challenges und
zweige zeugte von mir die des challenge
auf deutsch heißt das ganze ich erwarte
heuer alter aktiv ist ein bisschen
umgestellt und zwar bin ich hingegangen
hab gesagt liegt mir auch ins netz wie
immer kurz eingeblendet einfach ein bild
von euch space von euch wer gefällt und
an darunter alter ich habe mich bestimmt
jetzt gerade so 1500 bilder zur auswahl
es war mir so viele was geschieht
deswegen wir noch vorgehabt auch im
zweiten paar kann folgt mir auf jeden
fall oder hättet mich da dann könnt ihr
auch dabei sein
und jetzt war
[Musik]
ist ja ganz logisch ich brauche jemanden
jetzt die ganzen ins netz oder instabile
eröffnet oder die ganzen in spa direkt
messen
dafür habe ich hier den juli dabei du
kannst jetzt gleich mit die ganzen
bilder zeigen und muss man immer das
alpha verrecken und gespanntheit man
kann ja heutzutage bei der jugend ich
mal sagen vor allem bei den mädchen sind
jetzt 13
oder sind die schon sitzen so weißmann
ich will sagen weil sonst ein leichtes
jetzt mal ein bisschen höher an gibt zum
nächsten fahrzeug auf jeden fall bis zu
lassen ein video beschreibung verlinkt
aber natürliches nassen video und jetzt
vertraue ich immer mein handy in die
hand okay das erste bild gefunden ist
vorweg das will ist hier natürlich auch
für euch eigentlich könnt ihr bei mal in
den kommentaren mit raten da bin ich mal
gespannt sei er natürlich vor
das ist so eine die wie für mich noch
jünger aus aber etwas seien schon älter
du weißt du wenn wir das jetzt wird
nicht böse wenn ich falsch liege aber
ich würde es seien 14 maximal 15 ok wie
aggressiv wechseln 16 größere julia
alter ich finde es immer so kraft die
junge zu schade dass ich auch sucht hat
junge zuschauer des jahres und in der
zweiten klasse youtube kurz letzten zeit
waren zu schleppen und der jüngste war
vier der 14
ich wüsste jetzt auf maximal maximal
absetzen ich sagte ich sagen ja
12.42 geschick auf dem oberen ist die
flüchten aber hier sie 12 8 11 11 7 auf
dem unteren ist sie 12 und auf den
moment soweit von unterschieden leute
gleich mal das bild an was ich jetzt ein
gemälde hat dort ist die 15 und auf dem
anderen war sie zwölf ich mein mit dem
siehst du auch aus die 15 ist jetzt egal
ich habe nicht mit zwölf das geschäft
aber endlich zu sechs die 15 okay leute
drittes bild kommt jetzt 32 aber diese
fehler ein zum spaß die können auch 13
seine können auch schon 17
die könnte schon 19 jähriger 19
irgendwann machen
ich sag mal jetzt 16 16
so viel älter oder spaß jetzt leute oder
endlich was hättet ihr zu weit in die
kommentare dazu nicht so heftig wie ist
einfach zwei aber sie hat die 16
haben wir einen jungen ringer abnahme
wenn man jung suchen immer ist dass es
macht ist wieder mit filter und wir 32
das ist so schwer
13 er ist gut erste des guten
noch einmal wird okay aber 315 ganz so
weit und werden etwas macht einfach der
filter glaube ich okay das nächste mal
jung nummer fünf hallo schöne katze
ebenso wie geistliche natürlich ob sie
denn herauslösen
keine ahnung 15 15 richtig gut 14 41
geleistet war okay aber nicht er hätte
auch schon weg sein kann so 14 uhr
ich darf mir zusagten 17 nein er das
macht das passte zu erwarten ehrlich so
bekommen zur person nummer 56 keine
ahnung war so heftig dass heftig dass du
echt heftig ist weil ich mich mal das
alter hfg könnte wieder komplett jung
werden bestraft als ehrlich sie könnte
auch 20 seien jetzt ungelogen vielleicht
seinem hundeführer ich weiß es nicht ich
würde sagen 19
ja nochmal nochmals neuester noch mal
näher kommen 18 16 alte 60 wir bedauern
die mittel aber ohne scheiß bei ihr
könnte man sagen facebook entweder ganz
oder ganz ein test ist und spaß und
jetzt ohne scheiß jetzt kommt voll ein
ich war komplett verzichtet was hast du
verschickt komm ja so ist das denn du
hast du wechseln
also nur sagen eigentlich alles drin
waren bemüht und wissen ist dass robert
das foto weis nicht also eine ins profil
ist genauso also wird von chile fotos
schwer
ich würde sogar 22 aber einfach ihr für
meine zielgruppe schon alles gibt es von
welche die ba 20 sind aber vielleicht
zwei prozent aber ich denk mal nach wenn
ich sage sind abfüll und herbst ist es
ausgedrückt helfen dann ist sie
wahrscheinlich wieder ist so breit sein
oder so ich sag komme ich sage das macht
für mich keinen sinn da muss irgendwie
ausweis oder sonst was ich versteh's
nicht es ist doch älter als 15 wie sie
sieht aus wie eine erwachsene welche
forderungen er in einem club und sie
sollen einfach rein gekommen weil sie
aus dem 18 mindestens und dann ist sie
einfach selbst wenn ich weiß viele
schätzen mich älter ein bisschen honig
unbedingt
ach so etwas ja nicht einmal kurz sagen
kann ich bin übrigens freitag und
samstag in dornbirn in österreich
kleines meeting creed oder was ist keine
ahnung wenn ihr in der nähe wurden kommt
auf die video kommen könnte nicht
treffen und ich glaub da gibt es noch
karten
ich habe keine ahnung kommt etwas besser
ich habe zu meiner richtig heftiges
rausgerückt du kannst hier nicht bei der
wenn die jetzt unter 17 ist dann komme
ich nicht klar
ohne spaß ich weiß dass jetzt schon aber
ich hätte fast gesagt so 21 zähler ist
los er ist sozusagen mag immer ich würde
sagen mindestens 17 machte allein für
die qualität von den wölfen das ich
bisher von der mindestens 17 und 18 15
das ist mir zu viel hier ist jetzt
vorbei mit dem format 15
nein dies ist uns liegt ist die schau
bis 5
sie liegt eindeutig das war es der tv
verteil heute so vielleicht verdarb du
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen die schon
gesagt der 15 vielleicht machen wir es
nochmal und zeigt auf jeden fall meine
social medias ab und sich mehrer weitere
bilder zu wenn ihr auch mit am start
denn bolts abonniert juli ist endlich
beschreibung verlinkt und ja wir sehen
uns dann morgen führt sie nun wieder im
raum kommt auch mal was kaputt da ist
mir was passiert beziehungsweise so was
hab ich bis jetzt noch nicht erlebt 6 ab
und wir sehen uns ein kaufmann